I think you were taught to memorize
things wrong since we first started to
speak we begin to get tested on our
memory I've sat hundreds of exams
memorized tens of pages of scripts for
theater learn thousands of new Concepts
in four years of medical school and
while this all looks effortlessly
impressive the truth is beneath the
tools this girl actually has a terrible
memory a friend of mine actually made me
summarize a full novel to them because
they could not believe I'd read it as I
couldn't tell them the name of a single
character or a pace I'd say the main
girl her dad the first guy she liked
even a medical report of mine from a few
years ago noticed and described my clear
problem with short-term memory so
needless to say no natural talent in
this department but I've never accepted
this problem I've always tried to find
ways to perform and memorize the way I
was expected to in school or university
otherwise
I wouldn't be able to become a doctor in
this process I've read experimented and
memorized so much when it comes to the
way that our brains store recall and
forget information today I'm going to
share all of that with you let's get
straight into it firstly we cannot
improve our memory without first
understanding how forgetting works we
like to focus on ways to be able to
remember and recall things better while
completely ignoring the sorts of things
that encourage us to forget and
therefore end up not really improving
overall and we can't be excused for this
for the longest time we used to think
that forgetting was this passive process
that we either were able to memorize
something fully and if this memorization
failed we were left with the default
which was forgetting this is absolutely
no longer the case in his book
forgetting the benefits of not
remembering Professor Scott at Columbia
discusses studies with zebrafish to
describe how forgetting is actually its
own very active process it has its own
neurotransmitters its whole own Pathways
and there are things can actively
encourage it to become activated and to
work and this is amazing because it
means we can discover and try to avoid
those things memorization and forgetting
are two separate active processes let's
see what progressing Norms have you ever
been on an exam looked as oppression and
gone oh yeah I know what this is about I
remember being taught this but you
cannot for the life of you remember the
actual answer
so this highlights a very important way
about how we store retrieve and delete
information so the way that memories
work in our brain is that they are just
not stored in these individual packets
almost everything has a cue or a tag
attached to it subconsciously or
consciously when we're looking for
information in our brain we actually go
to the queue first and we look at the
tag and then we find the memory that's
connected to it in this case for example
we might go oh it was it was our history
teacher but then there's so many things
she taught us so we can't find it there
and then we go oh it was it was the
bottom right hand side of my textbook
but there are so many things that are on
those pages and then we're like oh it
was on Christmas but we learned so many
things then so all of these cues do not
help for us to tag and find the
information that we need the answer to
this question what has happened here is
Q overload each of these cues has too
much memories attached to them and they
do not like this when it happens they
start to delete the information
connected to them and this leads to the
case that we just so the technical term
for which is transient for guessing now
there is a very good solution for this
which also activates our attentional
control system which was described by
the daddy of memory Alan Brady which is
basically the thing that grabs things
from our short-term memory into our
long-term storage where we want to keep
them and therefore increases our
motivation to do this this is novelty
new unique strong cues means memories
you dirt practically what does this mean
for your studying when I used to be in
school and I was struggling with a topic
that I found either too difficult or too
dense because it had lots of things to
memorize I would drop my textbook which
already has too many oversaturated cues
and I would go straight to YouTube and
watch MIT or Yale open courses which God
bless them they've taken me through so
much it's amazing but because this is
such a different context audio watching
University lectures on one small aspect
of that lesson that I found challenging
and therefore this is such a difficult
context to my normal classroom teacher
teaching that it would create a new cue
in my mind if it was a particularly
important subject to me I would also
read extra books or watch extra
documentaries so for this one
challenging memory I actually would have
so many unique new cues attached to it
that became almost impossible for me not
to memorize that thing because I had six
new cues popped to mind every time I
thought of it in an exam I would
absolutely smash these topics I still
remember so much about the chemistry of
cloning because of these lectures I
would definitely recommend this next
very frustratingly a huge promoter of
forgetting is learning itself the
analogy here is that our brain is not
like a hard drive but like a cassette
tape when we are putting new information
in it we are very often overriding
information that was previously there I
was semi-fluent in Turkish when I
stopped studying it and started French
and now I've almost completely lost my
Turkish whenever I think of a Turkish
word the French one comes to mind this
was also replicated much more reliably
in a study where where mice were made to
learn new mazes and the mice that were
the quickest and the best at learning
new mazes were also the ones that were
more likely to forget the old ones the
technical term for this is proactive
inhibition where there's an interference
from previous learning that leads to
progressing you might have experienced
this if you've scrammed for an exam and
learned new material last minute and can
actually find on your exam day that
you've forgotten or messed up what you
previously knew actually quite well and
therefore you perform worse overall in
your exam now how we avoid this
proactive inhibition is not to avoid
learning new things altogether but is to
be strategic about our crowning if we
are cramming last minute very last
minute for an exam I would recommend
that we never learn new things that we
have not learned before because this is
where we are overriding what we knew in
the past what we can do instead is cram
revise which is learn only the things
that you knew previously revise those as
fast as you want that's absolutely fine
and pray that they're the ones that
going to come in the exam and on the
other hand if we have a longer time to
cram or learn information or if we are
learning things that are in a similar
field it's really essential to do a mini
memorization and comparison with what we
knew before if when I learned French I
also revised the Turkish equivalent word
I'm giving a signal to my brain that I
actually need both of these and can you
store them separately it's much more
likely that I remember both rather than
overriding and forgetting things from
the past before I progress onto the ways
to address memorizing specifically I
have to say that actually the thing that
has had the biggest impact on my memory
learning and performance is
unsurprisingly the state of my brain
itself as I mentioned earlier I should
have always known I didn't have an
actual talent for memorization because
as a girl in class I would refer to
people as the second row on the right
and someone would tell them their name
and I'd be like yeah that's the person
because I couldn't memorize names at all
and yet because I was compensating so
much and trying all of these strategies
I don't think I even realized how bad my
memory was and everyone saw my e-pluses
and my theater and all the things that I
did and assumed that I had an excellent
memory when it came to facts this
progressed all the way into my
University years and it was only
recently when I was told by a medical
professional that I genuinely have a
poor memory that my memory became so
much worse now that I found out I was
labeled this way there's a study that
shows that young girls that are told
that they're bad at stem subjects
perform a lot worse than those that are
told that they are good at them and I
truly believe this is what happened to
me and I'm still slowly rebuilding and
focusing on improving my memory and
overcoming this year or so of having
just really bad memory performance in
general when you tell yourself that
you're stupid or you're less capable
than other people or that you're just
going to struggle with something you
genuinely do end up performing a lot
worse my confidence mood and happiness
determines so much more about my memory
and performance than any other specific
technique as much as I love everything
I'll be mentioning today I probably
refer a bit more to that doctors lesson
diagnosis and effect in the end of this
video but for now I do want to say the
Eugene charity and peace in order to
study things properly and the biggest
difference you can make academic
performance is sorting out your mental
health almost half of the videos on this
channel are in some form related to
therapy I've been in therapy for years
now but both online and in person and I
truly believe it is the only reason I am
able to cope with making these videos
alongside studying quite an intense
degree and dealing with all of the
problems both internal and external of
my brain this video is a paid
partnership with better help and I'm so
excited to finally have links to give
that are related in some form to therapy
I'm sure everyone already knows that
better Hub is a platform that connects
us to credentialed therapists for online
remote therapy the beauty of it in
particular is that you are a match a
therapist based on your preferences from
the get-go if you know what you like I'm
a particular fan of family systems and
bowler Theory so I can look for that but
if you don't know what you don't know
they will ask you questions that can get
you matched in the best way it's almost
expected that you shop around and you
find the best therapist for you and
because there are so many available it
makes switching the easiest that I've
seen anywhere before I could genuinely
go on for days about how much therapy
has changed my life and how much I
encourage it so because of that I've
made another separate mini video which
is unlisted on my channel and links
below so if you want to see the reasons
that I think people should go to therapy
that I do not hear mentioned a lot
elsewhere and also my top tips for
either starting as a complete not this
or if you've been out of the game for a
while kind of what advice I would give
myself if I was starting again that's
listed in that video below there's also
a notion template for free which will
have all of the top tips summarized
together so if you're thinking about
this that might hopefully be slightly
helpful I also have a link in my
description which is betterhelp.com for
Phillips that will give you 10 off your
first month so if you are interested in
starting or thoughts about this before
the sooner honestly the better because
of the sure size and reach of the
platform better help can remain one of
the cheaper options of therapy out there
and I've had an amazing personal
experience trying them out for a few
months actually before making this video
so I want to thank them so much for
supporting this channel but also for
making therapy more more accessible
which is something that I am incredibly
passionate about so back to memorizing
now an important reason memorizing a
sword is because our brains were never
meant to do it the way that we are
expected to Professor Justin at the
University of Toronto describes that our
memories are not there for us to go oh
she remember that time but they're there
help us make decisions we're supposed to
store what we understand or what helps
us understand things to make better
decisions this is called conceptual
memory but it is not what we commonly
think it is conceptual memory can be so
powerful because when done properly it
also means that ideas connect so well to
one another that they end up kind of
collapsing and taking less space in our
brain therefore making it easier for us
to store larger amounts and volumes of
the data so how do we actually do this I
always think of learning as either being
horizontal or vertical and the way that
we are often taught to learn or taught
things is in a vertical way what this
means is that we are given a topic and
then we are given details about this
topic that come underneath this is a
vertical form of things to learn and
this is terrible because it remains one
discreet thing and we just have to learn
about it it might even be turned into a
mind map but still it will have one main
topic and everything underneath it and
this is just very hard to memorize all
of these details it's super likely that
I'll forget one or a lot more of these
points here and sometimes I'll forget
that the whole condition exists and it
will be gone in the sea of endless
vertical conditions I have to learn
instead I learn things in a horizontal
way so let's say you have to learn about
retinal artery occlusion I'm not going
to learn this topic I'm going to go and
look at one of the symptoms that stands
out to me which is painless or Vision
because I know that there's at least one
more type of painless loss or Vision so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take one of the characteristics in this
vertical list and try to find all of the
conditions that have this characteristic
and this now creates a whole group of
eye conditions related to painless loss
or Vision all of them connected by this
one backed already this is much more
logical and much more likely to remember
that these conditions exist and when I
see them I know at least one important
thing about them which is that they are
painless loss of vision next as I start
vertically slightly expanding with one
of them when I see things that they have
in common either tests that need to be
done either cures that need to be done I
create another horizontal layer that
connects them with one another and in
this way I haven't just studied retinal
artery occlusion I studied a whole bunch
of things which are all connected to
this very strong visual cue of this
whole group this is 360 degree
memorizing because when we memorize
things in a book or when we take notes
usually it's very vertical it's top to
bottom it's never a bottom to top that
would be very confusing but all these
conditions exist in this horizontal
plane and there's no beginning or end up
or down left or right they're all there
together and therefore I can kind of
rotate it in my brain and connect it
with other medical conditions so it's
compressed it's flippable it's
expandable everything is really well
connected and much more likely to
remember a lot more about these
conditions than if I was creating
separate mind maps with them or learning
them completely as vertical lists the
next way to improve your memory has to
do with the immense power of intuition I
used to play piano when I was younger
and sometimes I would take a piece of
new sheet music to my teacher and ask
them if they would let me learn it with
them and they might have never seen this
before and they just sit down and
learned to memorize the piece so easily
even though this was a song they'd never
seen it before so I think it's very
non-controversial that experts in the
field are a lot better and a lot quicker
at memorizing information in that field
than someone who is a complete novice
and you don't need to spend 20 years to
become an expert in a subject to benefit
massively from this intuition because
this is what I realized I used so much
when I was younger in school now there's
something I have to admit when I was in
school and I was younger I would really
be a lot quicker at learning and
memorizing things than other people and
everyone would think oh my gosh like
she's so smart so this is not it's not
true this is not the reason this is not
the reason I was memorizing things as
well the reason I was memorizing things
well was because I had less to remember
people who were seeing things for the
very first time had no intuition no
concept of what was happening in their
brain as I do for a lot of things had to
learn a whole bunch of information me
I'd done prep if I have to learn
something I need to learn a tiny bit of
it because I know what became before
what came after I say oh yeah that's
probably where it happened so me
learning it is a lot easier which is why
I can learn more memorize more and do
things in a way that appears to be so
smart to other people so let me explain
how to do this let's say you have to
learn the wars in France in the 1800s if
I had to do this now do not have a clue
if I would see a yard plus minus 60 70
years 200 years
I don't know when that happened so
before even approaching this if you want
to memorize it well in a logical way
because you can use visual mnemonics but
that's a separate topic if you want to
learn it well what you can do is you
divide the whole 1800s into like 10-year
brackets and for every 10 years you
write the main thing that happened the
main person that was in charge or the
main political context and you just
learned this and so when you're in an
exam and you have a multiple choice
question for example you don't have to
approach every new date as though it's
just a bunch of scrambled numbers and go
like oh is it this one and try to
remember what the number looked like in
the textbook but you can use this
intuitive logic when you approach it
where you go well it can't be then
because then that was resolved and they
can't be here because that was way too
soon they were fighting about something
else so that's the correct date and this
is helpful for exams this is helpful for
learning the information because you
already have this thing built which does
not take that long you can then memorize
things a lot earlier because you have
this Skeleton on which to link things
the same thing can be said for languages
before learning a language it's great to
just hear it a whole lot because you
build intuition and when you're studying
it or trying to speak you can sense that
you're saying something wrong because
intuition is like I've never heard that
that that sounds wrong even though you
don't know the grammatical rules the way
we all speak our native languages
fluently even though we might not
necessarily be able to tell you why to
use that tense or form off a word these
things would also be stacked with one
another to create crazy efficient
memorization and learning when you're
creating dates that's a horizontal
timeline and instead of learning things
about one War what happened in one day
vertically you now put it in the space
where it can be really flexible and
moved around because you have a timeline
this is a visual representation it's a
really strong cue because you have to
find this information potentially
outside of your textbook to build the
timeline this is where you're
researching and adding external cues the
uniqueness to a methods of study the
intuition you build make it so much
easier to memorize this in a way that
you potentially will not forget for the
next 30 Years very lastly I earned an
odd so much in this video about adding
that little doctor's note and about
talking about the negative effects that
some things that doctors say have to us
as someone who in a few months hopefully
will be a doctor themselves rifles in
the end it's really important to mention
just how empowering or disempowering the
story that we tell ourselves can be and
how easy easy it can be to overcome
challenges when you don't think of them
as challenges and I was struggling with
this realistically I should have
realized a long time ago that I was
struggling with this I have a terrible
memory and I never knew it because of
the fact that I was compensating working
hard at it and believing that I could do
this and I wanted to do this and in this
last year it's just been really hard and
I feel like I've forgotten more than
ever because I just accepted the fact
that I'm worse than other people at this
thing this is a huge topic I'd
potentially want to do a whole other
video on if but if you do want a bit
more information about how therapy
specifically has helped you with this
that extra video I've made below should
help and clarify things and also if
you're cautious about therapy I know
it's really scary it takes a while to
get into it especially when it's online
so if you made it so far
thank you so much for watching me and I
hate to the end of this video I hope you
have a wonderful recipe day be kind to
yourself and others and don't believe
everything you think thanks bye